speaking of the flooding in Louisiana we
now know that flooding has killed 13
people at minimum it is damaged at least
60,000 homes across 20 parishes we have
more video from member Roland Spano jr.
longtime member who has been working in
rescue efforts and he actually drove
around and showed us gave a sort of a
tour of the horrific devastation take a
look at all right David this is what
disaster recovery looks like this is in
Livingston Parish Devon Springs was
helping my brother-in-law this entire
experience
people have
so just so much stuff uh stacked up
everywhere their trash and devastation
were learning a lot more not all of the
areas affected required flood insurance
so we talked about areas that should
have had flood insurance but didn't some
of the affected areas and this really
gets to us talking about climate change
and how sea level rise and so many other
issues are going to have a systemic
long-term impact here some of these
areas were not even considered so at
risk that flood insurance was required
yeah uh that's going to be inning
increasingly common problem right as
yeah it's sad and uh watch out it's it's
unfortunately not something you should
have to consider but if you live near
the coast be careful and many of the
climate deniers often refuse to even
accept the impact of this saying well we
can just move inland or whatever and
that's not gonna be a big deal will this
is also affecting food supply because
the high water in Louisiana and in
Arkansas have really hurt the country's
rice harvest much of the Louisiana crop
was harvested before the flood but not
all in Arkansas farmers had just started
harvesting before the rainy weather
began and now the flooding is really
damaged so farmers are losing out and
this is ye people who believe that
they're siloed oh I'm in the middle of
the country and I don't care about
people on the coast or just inland of
the coast if that next becomes the the
coastal area once the actual current
coasts are underwater I don't care well
we're talking about food supply and then
of course if food supplies damage the
income of those farmers will be affected
they'll have less money to go out and
buy tractors and machinery for people
Jason who say not my problem it's not
going to affect me it's it's such a
naive way to look at the issue of
climate change I think it plays
perfectly into Trump's a new platform
kick any worse yeah right i mean that
that's the way that and the
unfortunately the thing is people aren't
actually connecting what's going on and
indifference to climate change to what
we see and weather and climate are
separate but broader changes in climate
will exacerbate extremes
in terms of individual weather events i
don't know i mean people it's it's at
this point if you're still denying what
is going on i don't know that there's
going to be any science that is going to
convince you otherwise probably not and
you maybe you're not even a denier but
it's just hard for you to see the bigger
picture yet and how this affects
everyone and everything on the bonus
show today lewis is questioning some
viral online videos we will talk about
some defective military helmets made by
inmate labor and we will also talk about
ramen noodles replacing tobacco as the
currency of choice in some American
prisons those stories and more on
today's bonus show only one way to sign
up for the bonus show get instant access
by becoming a member at david pakman.com
slash membership patriot 40 as a coupon
code hey tree at 40 will still get you a
forty percent discount